hi there and welcome to little Garden on
the Prairies so this afternoon I am just
got off work for the day and it's a
beautiful evening it's just about the
middle of May and I'm out planting my
onions that I started from seed I've got
them planted in containers I've been
doing that for a few years now and it
has been working out pretty good so um
I've got it started here and then I
thought you know I should be filming
this just maybe sharing a few things
that I've learned a few tips uh about
Planting onions I'm by no means an
expert on it um this is something that
I've just been doing for a couple years
doing them from seed so I'm just going
to show you how I plant up my onions
maybe give you a few tips so let's get
started so one of the things I learned
about Planting onions is it is kind of a
slow and tedious process so if you're
doing it in containers like I am here
it's very hard on you back to bend over
you're doing it in the ground crawling
around on your hands and knees that can
also get a little strenuous so this is
why I'm got my handy dandy Garden kner
here I'm using it today to sit on so I
can be really comfortable while I am
slowly planting these onions so I highly
recommend one of these what no matter
how old you are this is such a wonderful
thing to have in the garden it just
makes everything so much more
comfortable your back back doesn't get
sore your knees don't get sore I was
using it indoors this winter crawling
around in my grow tent as a kneeler and
now I've been using it as something that
I can sit on comfortably right at the
level of my containers and really enjoy
you know the planting
process so this is what a container of
onions like I started looks like and as
you can see they're planted fairly thick
in here and that's not a problem at all
they're very easy to pull apart once it
comes time to
[Music]
plant so you can see here these are the
red onions that I've been planting in my
container and they can they come apart
really easily like this you can just
basically pull them apart The Roots come
up come apart from each other quite
easily just make sure your soil is you
know moistened pretty good when you're
doing this and they are very easy to to
pull apart you don't have to worry about
hurting the roots and then they are
ready to get planted
up so I started off by freshening up my
containers here with some some new
potting soil I mixed up some Pete Moss
and some potting soil here I'm just
going
to add that to my
container so I just like to loosen up
last year's soil and mix in some of that
fresh stuff that I just added
[Music]
then I like to just top it up with a
little uh allpurpose
organic fertilizer here so I'll just
sprinkle some of that in and work it in
as well
[Music]
so I found some of this in my garden
shed this is granular bone meal which is
good for root growth stimulation so this
is something that will be good for
onions so I'm just going to add a
handful of that into here as well
[Music]
so once you got that all worked in you
got the soil all loosened up you're
ready to start putting your onions in so
the ones I'm going to start planting
here are their wala wala onions and
these are known as a long day onion
which is the kind of onion you want to
grow here in my growing zone 3 where we
have long days of sunlight starting now
until you know mid July so these like
about 12 to 16 hours of daylight so
these are a great onion to grow in this
area so I'm just going to grab a handful
here and start separating them not sure
if all of these are going to fit in this
container
so just kind of gently tease the roots
apart as I said they won't harm them you
can just kind of pull them apart and
they'll come apart fairly easy
then I just kind of slowly start pulling
a
few
out as you can see they have super long
roots right
now looking pretty
healthy and the thing is about Planting
onions is you don't want to plant them
too deep you want to just make sure you
are getting those roots under the soil
and just just covering up not too much
of what's going to be the bulb of the
onion you want that to grow basically on
top of the soil Not underneath so just
remember that when planting don't plant
these too
deep so just to dig a little bit of a
hole make sure those roots are all in
there and just kind of push the dirt
around
that area that's going to ball Bo
eventually and Pat it down
so these will kind of look a little
floppy at first when you plant them up
but once those roots take hold and they
gain a little strength your onions will
start growing tall and
[Music]
strong so like I said it's a bit of a a
slow tedious process doing this can take
a little while so make sure you give
yourself enough time make sure sure
you're
comfortable cuz this can get a little
hard on the back after a
while and I don't really worry too much
about spacing just kind of keep in mind
how big you know an onion can get and
make sure you have space I will plant
them probably a little thicker than we
should but I will thin them out
throughout the summer you can pick the
small ones and you know eat them cook
them with them and just use them in
salads or whatever and kind of thin them
out naturally throughout the season that
way so besides the wala wala I like
growing a red onion as well I do some
green onions also from seed I got some
started in my winter sewing
jugs and if I find I have some empty
containers or space in the garden once
everything's planted up I probably we'll
grow some more onions are something that
are so easy to store in the winter they
don't require a whole lot of preparation
just keeping them in a cool dark place
is all you need to do and we pretty much
cook with onions every day so can never
have too many
[Music]
and usually later on in the season when
those onions start to bulb you can do a
bit of a uh spooning around them just to
kind of keep that dirt clear and you
know give uh space for those onions to
really bulb
[Music]
out so after you get them all planted in
you know they they kind of don't look so
great they look like you know they're
all kind of flopped over and don't look
so healthy but like I said after a week
or so those roots will you know take
hold and they will start standing up a
little straighter so after I've got them
all planted here I'm just going to give
them a good watering sometimes you can
even buy these uh seedling onions
already planted in uh green houses you
can just bring them home separate them
like I showed you and plant them
up get everything well watered in
and then I like to kind of top it up
with a mulch of dried leaves I'm just
going to give it a day here just to kind
of let them take hold of the soil a
little bit before I cover them up with
some dried leaves which I still need to
uh collect I got a bunch around in the
hedges here I need to rake up and
collect so that I can start mulching
everything that I've been planting here
in my garden this spring so I will keep
you updated on how the onions are doing
and I hope you will keep following me
along on my gardening 2024 outdoor
season and please hit that like button
leave a comment and don't forget to
subscribe so you don't miss out on
future videos coming to the channel
thanks for watching